[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cent quarante mille cent quarante mille
objets électroniques seront vendues à la
fin de mon tour avant de vous parler de
la technologie qui nous entoure
j'aimerais bien vous dire quand j'ai
décidé finalement de devenir ingénieur
et pour ça je vous emmène dans le
grenier de la maison de mes parents ou
mon père avait mis en place un circuit
de train un circuit train comportant pas
moins de 10 locomotives et avec mon
frère ont joué des heures à sec ce
circuit de train je vous avoue que j'ai
été assez impressionné de voir mon père
autodidacte d'avoir été capable de
mettre en place ce circuit train
j'étais aussi fasciné par ces composants
électroniques avec ses composants
électroniques des possibles vraiment de
piloter l'ensemble de ses trains sans
aucun problème j'avais 12 ans et j'ai
dit je veux devenir ingénieur ingénieur
électronicien et dix ans après je suis
ingénieur je suis formée pour développer
des technologies efficaces rentables
je suis ingénieur pour travailler sur
ces technologies qui transforment le
monde
moi personnellement au début je voyais
de cette technologie comme étant des
outils fabuleux pour découvrir le monde
pour l'explorer pour le le décrypter
mais l'homme évidemment a vu qu'il était
possible si de façonner l'environnement
dans lequel nous vivions c'est le moment
de l'industrialisation 19e 20e siècle et
on voit cette technologie se développer
on voit la naissance d'un micro
électronique et le domaine dans lequel
je travaille aujourd'hui on voit
apparaître ce cet objet que l'on a tous
aujourd'hui
cet ordinateur personnel ce derner
personnel qui est mis maintenant réseau
par internet on voit développement
tablettes de smartphones et aujourd'hui
nous sommes submergés d'un nombre
impressionnant d'objets 50 milliards
d'objets connectés autour de nous alors
on est arrivé vraiment dans l'air de la
techno économie tout et technologique
tout la technologie est là pour soutenir
une économie une économie capitaliste la
croissance toujours cette recherche de
croissance et la technologie est là pour
avec tous ces efforts va contribuer
malgré elle au développement de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui cette expo naissance
programmé cette obsolescence qui est
bien présente et on peut vraiment sentir
que l'homme est prisonnier l'homme est
vraiment prisonniers des technologies
qui l'a imaginé inventé développer
lui-même
on voit que deux sociétés fassent des
crises des crises systémiques
crise économique crise sociale crise
climatique et face à ces crises
on sent fortement une polarisation de la
population on sent que d'un côté on a
des techno optimiste qui pour eux
finalement la technologie va résoudre
tous les problèmes du monde le
philosophe français jacques ellul dit
dieu est mort vive la technique
effectivement et la raison on a vraiment
l'impression que cette technologie à la
naissance finalement d'une nouvelle
religion vient d'un autre côté vous avez
les doutes techno sceptiques qui pour
eux au contraire c'est la technologie
qui est à l'origine de tous les maux de
notre société
et eux ils prônent les low tech
il prône la sobriété la sobriété
heureuse de pierre rabhi et on est en
droit de se poser
où sont ces scientifiques qui sont ces
scientifiques que font-ils alors bras
première question qui sont ces
scientifiques dans des mecs dans le
domaine des sciences et technologies ces
scientifiques correspondent à 0 8% de la
population active en europe ce sont les
maîtres les maîtres de
deux oeuvres de toutes ces technologies
on a à peu près un tiers de femmes et
deux tiers d'hommes donc les femmes
participent au développement ces
technologies
et quand on regarde le nombre de femmes
qui sont en réalité aux manoeuvres qui
sont dans les postes de décision là ne
tombe plus qu'à 3% donc l'ensemble des
technologies qui nous entourent sont
vraiment défini par les hommes pour iso
demandé aussi comment sont ils formés
ces scientifiques où je dirais même
comment sont-ils formaté peut voir que
la formation de ces scientifiques se
fait à l'université et l'université 10
pensent vraiment des cours très
disciplinaire c'est court ces projets
sont rarement interdisciplinaire il est
très rare de voir des cours qui sont
organisées entre différentes facultés
l'environnement dans lequel les cours
sont donnés ou que les chercheurs
pratique leurs travaux et extrêmement
challenging extrêmement compétitif on
prône vraiment l'individu et non pas le
travail collectif pourrait voir à
travers vos cours que vous suivez est ce
que vous avez vraiment le temps du débat
est ce que les professeurs dans le
domaine des sciences et technologies
prennent le temps de débattre de dire
est de porter l'étudiant l'esprit
critique développer l'esprit critique au
sein des cours je vous avoue que quand
je suis arrivé dans ce constat moi qui
parlais de cette fascination des
sciences de technologie abbas était
vraiment un désenchantement pour moi le
fort heureusement ce désenchantement fut
de courte durée parce que le doyen delà
de l'école polytechnique de louvain me
demanda de faire une mission une mission
burundi est arrivé au burundi bon à
visiter énormément d'endroits beaucoup
de villages et très rapidement quelque
chose est apparu à moi c'est les
questionnements les questions posées un
besoin a besoin finalement de technique
a besoin d'eux pour répondre à des
besoins vitaux
c'était moi en tant que bons ingénieurs
face à ces questions techniques posées
et par réflexe la mémoire par exemple un
endroit dans un village où la
problématique était l'accès à l'eau
potable
par réflexe tout de suite évidemment
où est la rivière la plus proche
avez-vous des nappes phréatiques à
proximité et joue n'oubliez plein
d'autres questions ne fut-ce que
demander comment faites-vous aujourd'hui
quelle est la quantité doukan fait que
faites vous avec cette eau qui est en
charge d'aller chercher ses taux les
femmes des enfants comment le travail
l'organisation la répartition des
responsabilités du village et nous
arrivant avec une technologie nous
allons je dirais modifié à impacter
l'organisation et donc je ne posais pas
à toutes ces questions et suite à cette
mission vraiment et une phrase qui est
apparu très clairement dans ma tête
la technique ne peut rien seul oui la
technique ne peut rien seul pour moi
cette phrase résonne encore très fort en
moi aujourd'hui je sors de cette mission
je reviens au laboratoire retour dans
l'équipe de recherche et la retour sur
les discussions des questions
scientifiques dans le domaine des semi
conducteurs
hélas lors d'une réunion je suis assez
frappé frappé de prendre conscience que
finalement l'ensemble des travaux de
recherche que je mène dans domaine de la
microélectronique et d'idées par une
seule loi la loi de moore
alors cette loi elle nous dit donc moore
si vous voulez c'est un ingénieur c'est
le cofondateur d'intel et cette loi nous
dit doubler le nombre de transistors par
circuits intégrés tous les 18 mois et
votre technologie sera rentable
aujourd'hui vous pouvez trouver des
ordinateurs au niveau du microprocesseur
plus de 10 milliards de transistors dans
les mémoires que vous avez plus de 400
milliards de transistors sur quelques
centimètres carrés 400 milliards c'est
le nombre des toiles dans notre galaxie
donc tout à fait impressionnant c'est
fascinant
et quand on connaît l'origine de cette
loi
cette loi est
sûrement une loi économique
cette loi ne fait pas référence aux
besoins réels de la société
cette loi ne parle pas de l'impact de
ces technologies au niveau
environnemental ou au niveau social on
est finalement si vous voulez dans le
réflexe de l'ingénieur je parle ici du
domaine de la microélectronique mon
pourrait prendre des exemples un peu
dans tous les domaines on est face à un
problème on vient avec l'apport
technologique
on est fier d'apporter une réponse ça
flatte notre ego et on accepte une
contrainte la contrainte face à la
contrainte économique
moi ce que je rêve s'est transformé ce
problème ne pas s'attarder à regarder
nécessairement au point de départ un
problème le regard des choses bien plus
en amont et de parler de besoin quels
sont les besoins de la société de venir
avec mon expertise qui est dans le
domaine des sciences et technologies
d'essayer d'apporter une réponse en
collaboration étroite avec l'économie
l'économie n'étant plus vu comme une
contrainte mais vraiment comme un
partenariat on va travailler ensemble on
va essayer de changer ce modèle
économique pour lutter contre ceux de
l'essence programmés et évidemment
l'économique et la technologie
ce n'est pas le tout il faudra apporter
aussi les expertises social législatives
environnementale politique pour être
dans une réflexion globale et adopté
cette approche holistique convaincu de
l'importance de cette approche
holistique
il ya maintenant cela six ans en
collaboration avec nouvelle coopération
a mis en place un dispositif pédagogique
un dispositif pédagogique où on met des
étudiants de notre secteur des sciences
et technologies en collaboration avec
des étudiants du sud
et l'idée c'est d'essayer de répondre à
certains besoins des populations des
pays du sud
mais le faire en collaboration avec les
loups cours avec ses ingénieurs
travaillant dans les écoles par les pays
du sud
pendant un an ces étudiants de
l'université de louvain vont travailler
avec les étudiants du sud ils vont
échanger leurs idées leurs points de vue
on va leur inculquer un peu de savoir
donc ils suivront des cours
il y aura du savoir faire ce qu'ils vont
réaliser des prototypes et surtout du
savoir être parce qu'ils vont finalement
après un an d change d'idée se retrouver
sur le terrain pour implémenter la
solution technique d'imaginer en
quelques chiffres
ingénieux sud c'est plus de 100 projets
une quinzaine de pays concerné une
vingtaine d'universités et pratiquement
700 étudiants ont suivi ce cours à la
fin de cette année académique et c'est
intéressant pointe et sakura options et
on voit qu'on a une belle répartition
entre le nombre de filles et de garçons
qui suit ce genre de cours 52 % de
filles 48 % de garçons
alors avant de terminer je voudrais dire
que là ce cours il a changé changer
vraiment je pense profondément ses
étudiants quand on parle avec eux avant
d'aller dans les pays du sud rencontrer
leurs leurs homologues pour discuter et
implémenter la solution technique n'est
pas rare d'entendre les phrases
suivantes à tout problème technique
existe une solution technique nous
allons leur montrer comment il faut le
faire on va aller les aider quand ils
reviennent de cette mission quand ils
reviennent quand ils ont fini finalement
secours on entend tout autre chose
on entend finalement j'ai bien appris
plus que je n'ai pu apporter au projet
il était
or temps d'interroger besoin de voir
l'historique du problème c'était
vraiment une partie passionnante de
pouvoir travailler ça ensemble de
d'approcher la problématique de manière
holistique donc sa marque
nos étudiants mais sa marque également
les enseignements les enseignants que
nous sommes et ça pour ça je voudrais
vous partagez en compte dernière
anecdote se retrouve dans un auditoire
je donne un cours de physique des
matériaux physique des semi conducteurs
après avoir fait quelques hypothèses de
physique quantique et après avoir résolu
et des équations de poisson on arrive à
la solution qui est le bismuth dix
minutes c'est un des matériaux du
tableau de mendeleïev voilà les
étudiants soeur de l'auditoire mais un
seul étudiant reste de son dû dans cet
auditoire
elle vient vers moi et me dit prêt sera
ce qu'un merci pour votre exposé mais
j'ai encore quelques questions pour vous
pouvez vous me dire quelle est la
quantité de bismuth sur la croûte
terrestre est ce un matériau toxique est
il possible de le recycler dans quelles
conditions on en train de l'extraire
aujourd'hui et d'y at il des problèmes
géopolitiques liés à ce matériel etc
pour moi cet étudiant avait tout compris
ou en tout cas il était sur le bon
chemin
après évidemment avoir eu cette
interaction avec cet étudiant je me
rendais compte je devais agir agir dans
notre propre de même à propre discipline
qu'est la microélectronique
il ya de ça trois ans j'ai donc discuté
avec un ensemble de collègues bien sûr
des ingénieurs mais aussi des
économistes des philosophes des
anthropologues les économistes pour
constituer un consortium européen
consortium européen qui essayent de
développer aujourd'hui des technologies
plus durable m
terminé j'ai envie de partager avec vous
un petit peu mon désir c'est qu'il faut
prendre le temps le temps du débat le
temps la discussion au sein des cours
chers étudiants professeurs scientifique
prenez ce temps mettez le débat dans les
cours en conférence et c'est pour moi le
chemin pour réenchanter des technologies
afin de développer cette technologie
pour définir un monde plus durable et
plus égalitaire
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]